I agree.
So we'll just,
it was briefly,
then you jump in there.
Ready?
Let me tell you what my deep research and basically vision is.
Okay.
It just means you're things crystallize epiphany.
To to talk about 12 dimensions,
11 known,
12 being omnipresent.
So we don't say it actually exists.
Yeah.
To say that is arrogance.
So I won't say that,
but I have had dreams my whole life that come true.
And the weirdest thing like,
Oh lady drops a thing of pickles at the store or for five years I have the dream
and then one day I'm there and it's the woman in the pickles break or,
or I'll her corner.
When was this?
Yeah,
chicken.
When I was a kid.
It was more intense ties.
Fucking crazy.
So you,
for five years he had the same dream that one day it happened.
Yes.
Was it exactly how you drempt ish.
Fuck.
For about six months I had a dream of a guy in a purple and green striped shirt
and I'm like,
why am I walking?
Cause it's not like normal dreams,
just like you're been taken over.
You always get vomit.
Like a lucid dream was a dream and I'm walking around like Lala behind a
building and all of a sudden there's some dude in a purple and green stripe
shirt.
He attacks me and six months later
it happens.
And I mean it happens.
Exactly.
So what do you think is going on?
If you mean all thoughts of yourself aside,
just,
just look at it objectively.
What do you think that is?
You could say that it's human programming and basic programming in the brain.
Do you think you're tapping into a timeline that maybe you can't access all the
time?
That's what I know of the reasons why you can rent.
One of the reasons why you can rant and rave and,
and when you spew out information that way you do,
which is at very impressive,
the way you can talk about the three hour straight and you do the majority of
your programs entirely by yourself.
No telephone.
I agree with you.
It's not like I'm going to tell you a little bit is you,
you're doing something unusual.
Do you understand that?
Not even doing it.
It's like a river's going by.
There's a turtle,
there's a fish,
there's a log.
I,
that's why it's like random like what does this,
what does that exactly right,
but that's how you communicate.
That's like in the beginning of the thing we were talking about Sandy Hook.
I kept trying to slow you down.
I was like,
I'm not following you down this river and you just hit this one rock.
I want to talk about this rock.
I want to talk about the next rock,
but you just keep going the way you think about things this year.
You're chaining one thing to the next thing,
to the next thing,
and for people who are not thinking the way you're thinking,
it can be exhausting like you're trying to follow Sam right about it all.
I'm only shame that like the code,
but I'm wondering because of the fact you're telling me that you had these
dreams that came true exactly the way you dreamt them.
I know you're not full of shit.
I've done.
You're not a liar.
I've known you for a long time.
If that really did happen to you,
if this is your real life experience,
I want to know what the fuck that is.
You are you,
are you on the periphery?
Do you have your finger on a membrane that maybe other people can't totally
touch where occasionally just occasionally you get a little peek through and you
get to see the other side,
even if it's once or twice in your life.
Who's to say that what you're experiencing by being able to see these things
that manifest themselves realistically in the future,
that this isn't what human beings will have five years from now or a hundred
years from now?
Well,
sure,
exactly.
We think of like a cell phone.
Me,
magic arteries,
we think we're all the same.
That's the thing.
We think we're all the same.
We're not all the same.
We're not all the same in our ability to talk.
You can talk for a lot longer about [inaudible] and I do.
Eddie Bravo could talk about Jujitsu better than both of us.
And he's a musician.
Sorry.
You and I both suck at music,
right?
So there's certain things that people can do that you can't let me try to
describe it and they'll use it against me,
but no to,
they don't touch it because just their whole religion and they can't stand.
I'm talking about it.
By the time I was like three years old,
I would have this dream that God has cause God knows everything is just super
intelligent,
omnipresent,
unlimited dimensions.
But God doesn't know where God came from.
She'll just like,
we're trying to find out where we came from.
God is like a virtual reality simulation as well.
And God is constantly running every program,
every operation,
turning evil,
loose,
good Lucia,
everything show,
I would have these dreams
but earliest memories like two,
three years old where I would fly out to the edge of infinity.
And
it was uh,
it was a continual message.
Find out where we came from,
find out what it is.
And it would just be this big giant spinning black vortex,
like a black hole.
And then I would have to go into that trying to figure out what was going on.
And it never,
it was the same thing.
And so it's this incredible frustration.
So then growing up and dealing with things in questioning politics and
questioning all these other areas,
then having dreams that come true.
Exactly.
And like knowing what's going to happen before it happens and then questioning
and,
and that it never being wrong be like weird,
crazy stuff man.
Like,
like just so much tough where it becomes like you can't even deal with you.
Like dial it out and then you just reached that point where
you don't even know what's real anymore because it's so crazy.
But then you see like the mathematics of the whole system and you know how it
works.
It's not like you're some schizophrenia,
you talk about it,
you deal with it and actually works.
Like now when you fight the system,
you automatically know what to do.
Like when you talk about something,
the president word for word repeats me.
Trump is what freaks them out.
Word for word,
a whole speeches,
like whole things.
And I'm on a power trip.
That's what they flipped out about it,
the CIA and everywhere else.
And they were like,
well Jones is like connected to trumpet.
I think Trump's like an idiot savant.
What does that have to do with this speech?
Explain that Trump speech.
Um,
I'm trying to follow it.
I don't even know.
It's a thing.
It's hard to follow you sometimes because we,
you're talking about God.
You were talking about Trump's Trump's,
well,
even before that he was talking about God.
Okay,
so God,
God knows everything except where God came from.
That's a good soundbite right there.
Do you think that God is just like every other system that we say like think of
this.
There's no one odd is the motion.
No one yard.
There's no one bird that's running all the birds.
There's no one person that's running all the people.
There's the,
it's all chaos.
Even if we elect someone,
if they have the fucking people hate him,
everybody's in chaos.
There's con,
they're trying constant power struggle.
Do you think that God has decentralized?
Do you think that the idea of God is decentralized?
That maybe God is a real thing,
but God's not one person?
God has literally three organisms.
God is not just freewill.
God,
it's consciousness.
It's all of the organisms.
It's every fucking technological innovation.
The God said new thing is a counterfeit.
Joe.
I agree.
Counterfeit.
No,
I'm saying I'm confident.
What's real?
Oh cause they all say,
Oh God has everything that was going,
it was true.
God is experiencing consciousness or all of us.
There's there's,
you know one of my,
where I have a hard time saying that I know this.
I could say God might be decentralized.
I could say God might just be just like every other organism on the planet.
It's just some thing that's moving in a certain direction and trying to protect
itself and trying to procreate and trying to advance and trying to innovate and
trying to be better than it was yesterday.
That's when everything is doing,
every fucking animal that started out as a single celled organism is trying to
survive because they create themselves.
Well,
it's not necessarily that it didn't create itself.
It's something created it slowly but surely and say this through the process of
evolution and mutation.
This is the,
he'd go on,
we'll keep going for hours.
We should do an epic podcast.
But the point is we should not give up.
Let's don't give up.
The point is there is a pro human future and a pro freewill future and the
globalist or,
or an anti human anti freewill future.
So all I know is just swim towards the light.
This is a good point,
zero human future.